Motors in Colombia's capital Bogota
elected a woman for the first time in
the city's history we united we won and
we made history
Flavio Lopez and openly gay politicians
running on a centrist anti-corruption
platform which is one of many surprising
results in Sunday's local and regional
contests in this usually conservative
country it's the defeat of the extremes
both left and right but I think the
biggest loser is the center of
democratic Oh party the elections were a
huge blow for the right-wing ruling
central democratic party of current
president even Dukey and his mentor
former President Alvaro Uribe both
fierce critics of the peace deal signed
with FARC rebels in 2016
their candidates not only came in last
in Bogota but also lost in Arriba's
traditional strongholds Colombia's
second city may be in and the province
of Antioquia the outcome of local
elections usually reflect the power of
political families and the major parties
but this time a number of independent
candidates one where the issue of
security used to be key in maintaining
traditional parties in power we are
thinking differently we are demanding
changes in our institutions and we want
our leaders to change their ways these
elections show that security is not the
only issue on the minds of Colombia and
voters but that many are now thinking of
defeating corruption and traditional
political machineries that have long
control politics in the country which
many here consider
brought by the peace agreement these
were the first local election since the
signing of the peace deal with FARC
rebels yet violence still Marta campaign
seven candidates were killed and dozens
attacked but on Sunday voting was among
the most peaceful in the country's
history
unfortunately political violence is
common in Colombia and it will continue
to be common unless we fill the vacuums
of power that were left by the former
FARC fight the paramilitaries who are
growing fight the drug trafficking
organizations that are growing and that
really needs a much more reliable
attitude on the national government
while Colombia still has a long way to
go to rail its politics of violence and
corruption Sunday's elections showed
that many voters are ready for change
Allisyn ramp et al Jazeera Bogota